van in a van yes the show is called the
Van Jones Show Evangel yep you have a
segment called been the van in a van and
you drive around while discussing issues
in a van and you're the driver are you
that confident that you're in your
driving skills because you're having
intense interviews while you're driving
you know actually it's funny I'm a
horrible driver I just lost three
potential tasks ya know I'm a terrible
driver not because I Drive too fast I
Drive too slow and so people are almost
always ruining me but let's get some
cameras in there exactly go wrong yeah
but what we do we take we take a liberal
we take a couple of conservatives we put
it all in the van we're all in the van
we have cameras everywhere and then we
drive around we went to Charlottesville
we drove past where the Nazis marshal
but we just have the conversation that's
the most recent show we took a dreamer
and put them in a car with two
Republicans mm-hmm and we drove around
and you know people it's interesting
because there are people I would think
what I found to be true is that when
people can dehumanize someone else if
they're not face to face with them yeah
but you put them in a van together and
they are there shared hatred of being in
a van it also might be better too if it
was a cargo van with no seats you took
corners real fast it's not a roller out
put the emphasis on the debate yeah yeah
you have a terrible producer I just want
you know I like Kenny's idea whenever
you hear something you don't like hard
[Applause]
but it's you know it's it is one of the
situations are where the disagreements
stay but the disrespect tends to bleed
away yeah and you know I think when
people are Twitter and Facebook and
synonymous it brings out the worst in
people
I like disagreement I like arguing I
like debate but it's got to be
constructive
it's got to be respectful so that the
end of the day you might actually get
someplace right and so that really the
Van Jones Show weird yeah we're saps in
that regard we think it's actually the
case that the problem in the country is
not that you got too many mean dumb
people doing mean dumb stuff we actually
have too many awesome people who just
don't know what to do right and so if we
can find our way back to the awesomeness
in each other if we disagree on some
stuff we might actually get someplace no
I like that I like an optimistic I'll
sign up for that second episode of your
show is this Saturday who's gonna be on
the show we're gonna have Megan McCain
she's gonna be on there yeah she's
amazing she's brilliant we're also gonna
have Malcolm Jenkins he of one of the
Philadelphia sheriff he's not going to
go to the White House so we're gonna
talk with him about about that and we're
also gonna have the van in the van show
down in Houston again dreamers
Republicans same van one of the people
in the van is a dreamer who saved lives
paramedics saved lives during that big
storm and six days later got his daca
revoked by Tron oh my god okay well this
is sounds like a show worth watching the
Van Jones Show airs this Saturday at 7
p.m. Eastern on CNN Van Jones best of
luck to you thanks what'd they do
[Applause]
you